looking overseas china is taking a hard
line against covid with the beijing
winter olympics less than two weeks away
one district in the capital is being
targeted this morning under the
country's so-called zero covid policy
millions of people have been told not to
leave the area elizabeth palmer looks at
the country's maximum effort to keep the
virus from disrupting the olympic games
all the residents of beijing's fungtai
district lined up in the cold for
mandatory covid testing this weekend
after 31 cases were reported locally
and with the opening of the winter
olympics just 10 days away smaller scale
testing was going on across the city the
overwhelming priority is to stage an
olympic spectacle mainly for tv
virus free
the venues are ready
there's even fresh snow at some of the
alpine locations but to minimize any
chance of outbreaks local people aren't
allowed to buy tickets
instead spectators will be specially
screened groups chosen from inside china
meanwhile from outside china olympic
athletes and officials have begun to
arrive they're being tested at the
airport and then they have to enter
what's meant to be a coveted free bubble
the so-called closed loop
which means they'll be confined to
fenced off areas and ride special buses
between their hotels and the sports
venues
but already the chinese say they've
picked up 78 coveted cases among
travelers arriving for the games
and the influx has only just begun
the chinese authorities are so hyper
determined to catch every single covid
case that people who go to the drug
store these days wanting cough and cold
medication say or something to bring
down a fever automatically get an alert
ordering them to go and get tested
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer
bangkok